go to
this volume
Pagli has said that since ancient times there are some such powers among us which have
come in this system
that
this is the story
that the god of all these weapons has
Brahmastra
and a secret young man is unaware of the fact
that he  Brahm Dutt's destiny was a
leak of Shiva Om's gas.
Who are you?
Come, you too should join me. I am about to
reach home.
Why is your hand when I tell you,
I will meet you some time to see if
his marriage is also there. Is there
anything going on?  There are some
old powers in the world and some of them can be kept.
Father-in-law, Nandini, I will understand, still there is a lot of
indiscriminateness of long journeys, but there is also a darkness, the well will
destroy everything, don't
you bow down to this world of clothes of ours
because  You watch a lot,
do your porn,
do
9th
and Papa ji
's film
hua hai
loot lo
[music]